here's a few facts everybody loves free
we love games this guy loves Friday and
he's only a matter of time before they
came together to form the Holy Trinity
that is free games Friday let's start it
off by talking about the game that's got
everyone showing off their fancy decks
hearthstone originally released as a
free-to-play digital collectible card
game for pc and mac but now deals damage
to the ipad as of April sixteenth choose
one of nine heroes collect cards and
build your deck to fit your most
destructive tendencies popular cards
include the flame strike that can take
down most mid-game defensive lines and
even have mana to spare or the leroy
jenkins that charges fearlessly into
battle with the famous fry your stupid
as hell leroy we've got chicken the game
plays just as well on ipad as it does on
pc tap your targets to lay down your
intensely gratifying spell and then rub
your belly and sweet sweet victory from
the makers of Far Cry the crisis series
and Fibble flickin role comes the
military FPS that's starting to turn
some heads allow me to set the stage
here in the midst of a super poor city
bunch of rich jerks created blackwood
super corporate army that hates poor
people in nature a bunch of penniless
losers got sick of being treated like
trash called themselves war face and
started writing bullet checks to the
fancy monopoly men that oppressed them
but unlike real life battles between the
rich and the poor this war is super
balanced and you can change places at
any time you play as one of four classes
soldier like skull face engineer or this
sniper that really sucks at hiding I can
totally see you for the price of the
time it takes to download to your xbox
you can start playing and finally we
travel to the jewel of the North for a
game made by D&D fans for dnd fans it's
called neverwinter and GameSpot hooking
you up with a super exclusive mistica
companion and the neverwinter vanguard
pack full retail value of 20 bucks for
free this
d MMORPG allows you to play one of six
character classes and then form a party
of up to five pcs without ever rolling a
20-sided die there's a lot of
large-scale quests and intense PvP but
what you're really gonna like are the
player created quest where the
creativity and level design flock at the
salmon of capistrano the only way to get
this companion is through gamespot so I
suggest clicking on the links below this
video the cleaner please stop unless
you're not into that that's it for this
episode but i'll be back with more free
and more games next friday see ya